can you please not look at me go play
with your toys come on come on in poop
just poop here ready food you poop gooey
poop Oh No
why why would you do this you contribute
nothing I'd like to know how to those
tiny little nostrils you get enough air
into your lungs to survive in this world
poop please poop poop no you are done if
you don't get any more people food
no okay find here oh my god they're best
friends immediately you made a friend
this is who I used to date and this is a
dog I used to know this could have been
your brother I thought it was gonna be
your brother but you guys would have
gotten along oh wait you're all good
dang Gager that's what I'll do
you poo where we stay here all day this
is good I love you so face it we think
about I love you so much
I'm seeing nothing without you I would
die for you
and kill my own family for you if that's
what it took that's what's [ __ ] up is
I would and the thing is you deserve it
coz you're pure I'll never be pure
you're pure
[Music]
well what is where I'm staying
you me you did it good good god you did
so much of it oh yeah oh god what's on
my end
I'm sorry bunkies hehehe longingly what
it's so little gah
what's on my end I'll sign if he's there